if you saw atomic blonde you remember
the hallway scene it's all done in one
take and ends with Charlize Theron
jumping out a window except in some of
the scene it wasn't really her it was a
stunt double the name you don't know is
Sam Hargrave he was the movie stunt
coordinator and was instrumental in
crafting what was by far the movie's
most memorable scene and though he
helped construct one of the most
talked-about scenes in cinema this year
there's no way for him to get awarded
films top honor despite their efforts to
change this some people still don't have
an Oscar category I've heard every
single you know decision as to why they
don't want us in there but none of them
make any sense
and the public wants to send their our
peers want us in there stunt people are
some of the most vital crew members
behind the scenes of any movie stunt
performers pull off the riskiest and
often most memorable scenes of any given
movie the stunt coordinator meanwhile
works closely with the director and
intricately plots out how stunt
sequences and thus all the movies action
will look create the roller-coaster ride
there have only been two occasions when
stunt people are honored by the Academy
the first time was in 1967 when yakima
canutt received an honorary award for
his contributions to the stunt world
such as his legendary work on 1959 s Ben
Hur the second time was in 2012 when hal
needham received a Lifetime Achievement
Award for stunt work on movies like
Smokey and the Bandit
action movies have actually had a
surprisingly strong presence during
award season in recent years so the lack
of a consistent stunt coordinator Oscar
award doesn't make a lot of sense when
you think of the movies that some people
could have gotten nominated for
[Music]
this is J Lynch he's a stunt man living
out in Los Angeles
how about performance every single scene
in that movie showed performance of
stunt performers
not one single stunt performer got
recognized for any stunts not one stunt
coordinator got recognized for any of
his work the stunt community has spent
years fighting back this is Jack Hill
he's a veteran stunt coordinator who
worked on the Fast & Furious movies and
he's been leading the charge to get
stunt coordinators their rightful place
at the Oscars for nearly three decades
now
Gill thinks the Academy looks down on
action movies he's heard the argument
from Academy members that there's
already too many awards shown during the
live broadcast but he's not even asking
for it to be shown on TV right now I'm
not making any progress in trying to get
in the televised events I'm trying to
just get us up non-televised
in some hotel somewhere maybe on the red
car red carpet just to say we want our
own Oscar and we're among our peers
somewhere in there
for the time being they are focusing on
getting a category for stunt
coordinators guild whoops a stunt
category would be given a name that
truly describes what a stunt coordinator
does best action designer there have
been hints of progress along the way up
until relatively recently no one from
the stunt community was even part of the
Academy the group of Hollywood folks
that decides which films to nominate for
Oscars and who gets what award it was
1992 when people from the stunt
community were officially allowed into
that voting body and that was all thanks
to Jack Gill he kept paying to get stunt
coordinators and stunt people a foot in
the door in the Academy the Academy is
made up of branches for example their
branches for cinematographers costume
designers and writers and a
corresponding award for nearly all of
those branches right now all the stunt
people are in the uncatted Erised group
called members at large there are 49 of
them Gil's plan to eventually get the
Academy to recognize a branch for stunt
coordinators
with an award following shortly
thereafter but that's not necessarily
guaranteed to work while most branches
of the Academy have a connected Awards
category not every single one does
for example casting directors the
smallest branch in the Academy with one
hundred sixteen members has no award in
a statement an Academy spokesperson told
insider stunt coordinators play an
integral role in many movie productions
and those at the top of their craft are
invited by their peers to become Academy
members we continue to encourage them to
grow within our membership so it sounds
like it might be a numbers game if the
stuff community gets enough it could
mean getting a branch and then an award
but the academy spokesperson wouldn't
say definitively that there would or
would not be a stunt award in the future
gills campaign has frequently drawn
media attention from his protests
petitions and his extremely strong
message I'm not really worried about
burning bridges at all because it seems
like the people I work with are for it
in fact
he's earned allies from Hollywood
heavyweights like Steven Spielberg James
Cameron and Arnold Schwarzenegger this
is melissa Stubbs a stunt coordinator on
movies like Deadpool and ant-man she
prefers working the system from the
inside to fix the problem it's been a
very aggressive approach of we are stunt
people hear us roar we're gonna pick at
the Academy and I think that there's a
different way to negotiate so that our
voice is heard if you demand something
after a while you're going to be ignored
but if you're willing to sit down and
discuss like intelligent filmmaker
creative filmmakers together to find a
solution to the problem - my approach
would be a little more gentle a best
action designer category would be about
much more than just the trophy at its
heart it's about long deserved
recognition
some people are Hollywood's invisible
stars you see their work almost every
time you go to a theater
and never realize it you might be
watching an actor or a stunt double and
you rarely know the difference for now
the fight continues for the stunt
community to actually be recognized
would be fantastic I feel that the
appreciation is the most important part
I mean at the point where you can't even
get recognized for what you do I mean
we're we're the movie's best-kept secret
[Music]
you